out here there is no good and there is
no bad to survive out here you got our
outlines to the monster can you do that
get my baby bye dad
everybody listen up Marcus you've got a
new partner allow me introduce Chris hey
so can we talk about this he'll know the
rules around here different you better
learn fast you for man how's your job
now trying to make a difference
we're family your job get home at the
end of the night let's make this one for
the books
Kyle just went out to a half moon rapido
what you got for me
why dealing with the formatting they got
pictures of my family be careful what
you against Google tweet pain
this guy's the leader you gotta ask
yourself is that fourth I don't make me
regret pulling you cops in for this you
all right yeah I'm good you the dog we
changing out the Frog Lions heart like
my name in didn't
I'm gonna find out what you're fixing
today does anyone believe something very
big he's about to go down I don't have a
problem taking out a cup there's got to
be a different way undo a cop just like
go I know that alone there is no limit
to what desperate men will do when
pushed to parolees attending our
meetings if you don't get off my back
give me a shove a box of chocolate
clusters up that tight ass of yours what
is all this this is my way back we are
gonna start a brownie